the bnd surveillance station in bot
ibling is still monitoring
communications but according to reports
in the german media the u.s won't be
getting as much data as before the bnd
is no longer sending internet
surveillance data to the nsa
this is a serious development and a
drastic step and long overdue it appears
it's truly astonishing that action is
only being taken now when the problems
have been known about since at least
2013.
the bnd had been forwarding data to the
nsa for years the u.s intelligence
service even told the bnd what search
terms to use
but the parliamentary inquiry still
doesn't know what the search terms were
or to what extent the nsa spied on
european companies and politicians
the government and the opposition both
say it's time for germany to re-evaluate
its cooperation with the nsa
and they want a complete list of search
terms used by the u.s intelligence
agencies
it's been made clear to our american
partners that the heat is on here
that the investigative committee is
putting on pressure
and that's a good thing
meanwhile the parliamentary
investigation into the scandal continues
several b d employees have been asked to
give testimony behind closed doors